it's been exactly one hundred and five
years since the fateful events that led
to the sinking of the Titanic
1,500 people were killed when the luxury
ocean liner struck an iceberg and sank
more than two miles to the bottom of the
North Atlantic for more than a century
many of the belongings of the 2,200
passengers and crew have sat on the
ocean floor but this week the public got
its first look at this a gold locket
owned by first class passenger Virginia
Clark it was recovered from the wreckage
in 1994 and put on display this week at
Titanic the artifact exhibition at the
Luxor Casino in Las Vegas the locket was
found in a bag along with a pair of
cufflinks and some poker chips which
helped researchers connect the dots on
who the bag belonged to we know that
when Virginia felt the ship hit the
iceberg she got dressed went to find her
husband who was playing poker in the
smoking lounge he left the game came and
helped her get ready and then put her on
a lifeboat movie fans may see a tragic
similarity between Clark's locket and
the necklace at the heart of the
blockbuster film Titanic like the movies
heroine Virginia Clark survived the
disaster her husband did not
if we can bring some more information to
that person what kind of person they
were what they enjoyed doing why they
were on the ship
it just helps us bring the story of
Titanic into the present there's a lot
of Titanic frenzy right now some company
is trying to 3d image the entire wreck
because in 20 years they think it may
all be mail disappear may melt into the
sea yeah so you're a bit of a Titanic
buff physics I think you can call me a
Titanic aficionado Anthony I think I
qualify things we're learning